今天這集不藏了
直接來 2025 AI簡報製作大全集
懶人包來了 各位你不能不知道的10招AI簡報制作技巧
今天的影片整合了各種免費可用的AI工具
不管你有沒有想法 或者是手頭有大量的文字資料
甚至你有大量的簡報
都可以1秒開掛
另外簡報製作最痛苦的找插圖還有圖表
智慧構件這些東西的制作 我們有解方
希望你從此不再爆肝一次影片全部學起來 時間到準時打卡下班
正式開始之前插播一個超猛的消息
AI教父黃仁勳 黃爸爸 這次居然要跟我們的好朋友泛科學頻道合作
下個禮拜一5月19號早上10點半
泛科學watch party 線上直播開起來
不只是看演講
還會同步拆技術
解應用 翻譯重點 完全不漏接
重點是呢
現場還會抽出黃仁勳親簽的NVIDIA RTX5090顯卡
各位 這可是花錢都買不到的S級的收藏
直播連結我發在影片下方資訊欄 這場真的絕對不要錯過
記得設好提醒
嗨各位又是我AJ
我知道你各位很多人都是因為我們當初那GAMMA教學才知道泛科學院的 對吧
但是兩年已經過去了 雖然說那支影片185萬了
但光靠Gamma還不夠
2025的今天 做簡報的AI工具早就全面升級
所以 今天這一集我們直接全部大公開
是說做簡報這種事情
不外乎就是以下四種情境 第一個叫做沒想法也沒有內容
說實話 很多人你連要做什麽都沒有想法
這時候還好我們用AI可以來幫你開開腦洞
第二種有想法沒內容 這是我最常遇到的就是你腦中有一些初步的想法
但是你不知道怎麽樣開展成一份完整的簡報架構
第3種有內容沒簡報 手頭邊有很多的論文 報告
但是你沒有時間把它做成簡報
第4種有簡報缺乏美化 你手上可能會有一些很醜的簡報
想要透過AI一鍵美化
或者是簡報里面你想要增加更豐富的一些互動式的元件
這個我們今天的影片裡面全部都會告訴你 所以記得要從頭看到尾
對了 趁現在快速感謝一下我們的頻道會員
尤其是這幾位泛科學長姐
感謝各位的支持
會員朋友每個月都會拿到990塊的AI課程折扣券
所以有在學AI想要升級自己的人記得用起來 不要浪費
感謝時間結束 馬上就進入我們今天的實戰教學
第一招 沒想法沒內容的時候 我們最近有個新的工具叫做Felo
比如說Felo我們之前教過這有什麽好教的
不不不Felo現在出了一個新功能叫做Felo agent
所以我們進去Felo然後簡單的給他登錄一下
那在這個Felo agent這邊
你可以找到AI簡報製作神器
點進去
就可以問他任何問題
比如說南部粽跟北部粽那個比較好吃 這個讓AI來幫我們制作一下
那剩下的都不用管他 語言可以稍微改一下
改成繁體中文
簡報制作神器 好送出
端午節快要到了
祝大家端午節快樂
那AI來幫我們分析一下南部粽跟北部粽哪個比較好吃
所以我們可以看到他啟用了深度搜尋這個功能
然後他開始整整理成這個簡報的差異
你看搜尋完我什麽我啥事都沒做然後就開始自動幫我生成簡報
他會幫我把搜尋到這個結果變成簡報的內容重點
重點好了 按下一步
然後你就可以在這邊選一個風格 生成PPT
好那你可以觀察到就是他通過這個Felo agent的動作
他會自動的幫你把你的搜尋結果變成簡報內容重點
然後再直接一鍵生成簡報
這個比傳統的那個Felo 搜尋出來結果的格式會更加的適合簡報這種格式
然後他也可以自動幫你生成二三十頁左右的內容
然後就可以直接下載下來 變成PPT這個格式
那另外很多朋友在看了菲Felo那集影片的時候 在下面留言問我說AJ
我們為什麽Felo進去之後我看不到那個簡報生成
那個下載那個功能 要記得登錄啊各位
記得Gmail登錄免費
不用綁信用卡
那有了這個Agent的功能
他會自動幫你把搜尋出來的結果直接在整理成簡報內容的重點
這個部分我覺得就是一鍵就可以完成
你們還不用自己去按那個生成簡報
自動處理到好了 你再按下載就好了
第二招是我們的好朋友Canva 那我們最近有一集Canva的那個AI的功能
那在AI這個地方 我會建議各位如果你要Canva做簡報的話
那你可能把你的Canva切換成英文界面
點選你的賬號 然後點設定
然後進來這邊改成英文US
那我們回到Canva的首頁
關鍵字直接就是在 不要開Canva ai
直接要求他說a create and presentation on represent about a vibe coding 101 teaching slide
那這邊有一個功能叫做design for me
中文版還沒有出現 我不知道為什麽
那如果你有找到那個為我設計這個功
Canva又更新了
好那我們錄影的當下還沒有所以你要切換成英文
然後點這個design for me
你可以要求他選presentation
然後你就可以按送出
那Canva呢
他就可以在他的這個模式之下 開始直接幫你生成你的某個主題簡報
那這個好處是呢
就是你不是在他從模板然後自己拉模板然後自己改製好
他可以直接幫你把這個簡報的內容直接做出來
然後還有不同的風格可以讓你 啊那就選個你喜歡的
比如這個7頁點出來 然後就直接use Canva editor
到這邊為止你就可以切換回中文 剛剛這個design for me已經下班了
你就可以再回到settings
然後把language改成中文台灣
這邊就回來了 那這邊都是英文怎麽辦
Canva還有一個功能叫做翻譯 所以在這個調整尺寸
里面有一個功能 叫做翻譯
它叫做魔法切換開關的功能
這個也不是新功能
這是舊功能
所以翻譯然後就可以直接把它從英文語言把它改成中文
原始 然後所有的頁面 然後翻譯現有設計 翻譯
這樣子7頁的這個Canva的簡報 就做好了
而且配圖配的也很好
缺點是他的簡報的頁數設計比較少一點
但優點是
你整份簡報在Canva上面做的時候
他的優勢就是
你可以在這個地方把它自由自在翻譯成各種各自各樣國家的語言
這個非常非常的方便
好那結合剛剛的那個 design for me就可以讓你一句話自動生成一份簡報
那接下來 就進入了這個有想法沒內容那我就可以跟Claude的講說
製作一個線上簡報的網頁
然後使用高橋流簡報法 送出
當你有想法有內容
那你把這些東西大致的大綱 丟進去給AI
好那這邊我們Demo這個 用的是Claude的預覽這個功能
讓他直接幫你生成一份線上的網頁
那這個網頁
我們又請他做了類似簡報風格的示範
那這樣子你就可以很輕松的把這些資料把它轉成一個簡報的這個形式
那我們可以看他怎麽樣跑
好 跑完了 你看左鍵右鍵就可以切好
然後可以按publish
然後publish and copy link copy你就可以到一個獨立的頁面
然後用左鍵右鍵
好 用左鍵右鍵來去切換
那ChatGPT有類似的功能
所以在ChatGPT的canvas里面
你可以直接要求用畫布模式
然後提示一模一樣 基本上 \也是可以生成類似的功能
好 我們簡單做一下 就直接用一個預覽 去ChatGPT 叫做預覽
Claude的叫做publish 那 Google Gemini
也有類似的功能
用2.5pro Pro canvas
他可以生成程式碼
Gemini一樣有預覽的功能
那可以看到我覺得Claude在這塊還是做的比較好 同樣的提示詞
Cluade的幫我加了一些料 那ChatGPT就是排版都沒有處理的很好
Gemini也是就標準而已但是就沒有到很細致
所以這部分我個人還是比較喜歡用
Claude的這個預覽功能 來做這樣的一個大字形的這種簡報
當你有想法你只要快速的要求他制作的時候
好是一個很方便的做法
可是這樣的缺點就是你沒法生成PPTX的這個簡報格式
所以我們 可以來到ChatGPT那換o3模型
然後就跟大家講說請以AI做簡報為主題制作個十頁的簡報
內容詳細
並且提供PPTx檔案給我下載
ChatGPT他會去理解思考
然後幫你直接把剪報做好
然後就直接給你一個PPTX直接下載 啥都不用想
然後就開始自動幫你寫
好完成 下載點一下
簡報就做完了 那你要說這剪報太醜了 沒關系我們後面還有一段
我再教你怎麽把這種醜醜的簡報 變成漂亮的剪報
簡報變得更漂亮呢
首先我們可以用到Gamma
進入Gamma後台之後你點選 新建
然後這邊有一個匯入檔案跟網址
然後你就上傳一個檔案
那你最好是傳PPTX
我們剛剛用 ChatGPT 簡單的做了一份 送出
送出之後 現在有一個新的功能叫做視覺效果匯入
它可以讓你簡報變得更加精美
這邊有一個重點 就是
Gamma免費版他一般只能生成7頁到10頁的簡報
可是這個視覺效果匯入 至少在我在測試的這個當下
他沒有簡報頁數的限制
所以你可以在其他的地方做好簡報之後扔進來     你只要有文字就好
內容大綱就可以了
扔進來然後要求Gamma去幫你做視覺效果匯入 那這邊會扣掉50點
那這邊 我們就一樣選一個風格
然後就按 continue
那Gamma就會幫你把你這個檔案 匯入了資料把它自動放進去
那剛好這一份也剛好只有10頁而已
不過我們自己實測了二三十頁他都沒有問題
他不會去卡你的那個簡報的頁數
好 然後好了之後就按繼續
Gamma就會幫你把這個簡報就是做一點簡單的美編
好那如果你運氣夠好呢 這邊就會出現一些圖片
那如果像我一樣今天demo有一點微翻車 你可以在這個AI編輯這個地方
好 然後你可以扣5點來嘗試新的排版
那左邊這邊就會給你各種各式各樣的排版的參考跟建議
你就可以依照你的需求喜好來去選了
比如說這個是原始的沒有圖
那我要一張圖
所以我就點這個
然後第二頁 一樣
請使用嘗試新排版 他就會分析你的這個簡報的那些原始的內容
然後提供你一些AI調整過的視覺化的形式
好 比如說我這個
你看從剛剛的那個只有文字到現在插圖
然後還幫我做了這個就是類似圖示
然後內容 工具總覽
一樣AI嘗試新排版
Logo icon都有出來
做的非常的好 所以這個是伽馬最新推出的這個視覺效果匯入
非常的好用而且沒有頁數的限制
推薦給各位再來下一招 比如說
我們有一個二十幾頁的資料長這樣子
AI in the enterprise
就open AI一個
公司企業導入這個簡報些導入的實作案例 那二十幾頁
那當然Notebook LM
你丟個三五百頁進去他也都可以吃的
倒進去把資料丟進去 那為了demo簡單我就用一個簡單的不要太多頁的
那重點是什麽
重點是 請根據我提供的資料生成11頁檢報重點  包含檢報標題與內容大綱
使用Markdown
格式輸出
如果你有大量的資料
不管是一堆的PDF word不行word你要轉PDF Notebook LM他可以吃大量的資料
我們就要得到一個哦Markdown的這個內容重點的跟格式
那我們就把這個Markdown的內容重點覆制下來
那我們這次一樣回到Gamma那這次我們選的是貼上文字
然後把這東西貼上去 然後按繼續
繼續之後 你的原本的資料會從自由格式轉化成逐卡片
Gamma他的吞吐的文字數量受限於模型的限制
他用的模型應該是比較舊版的ChatGPT模型所以他沒有辦法吞大量
所以我們會使用Notebook LM 使用Google的Gemini大模型
來去把我們的大量的重點資料變成簡報的重點
那為什麽是11頁
因為Gamma免費版最多就是10頁
扣掉封面頁 我把它刪掉
那我就獲得了十頁 這個空白頁刪掉 這樣我就獲得十頁 扣掉40點
生成
那這樣子 我就可以透過伽 Gamma
快速的把剛剛的簡報內容重點 再快速長成一份漂亮的Gamma的內容跟簡報
那因為受限於Gamma免費版的頁數限制一次只能生成10頁
好所以如果你的Gamma是付費版那最多 我沒有記錯應該可以最多到35頁
那你在NotebookLM生成內容結構的時候就可以要求他生成36頁
然後把封面砍掉
根據你剛剛的這個企業AI導入指南 快速的就生成了一份
你可以拿去上課分享那些簡報
那當然就我的觀察
他在生成內容的時候因為我們剛剛只給他標題跟這個內容的重點
那下面的這些文字有可能會是錯誤的
正確與否 就要你自己去做一些內容的判斷
那這樣子你就可以直接按點點點 然後按匯出
然後就直接匯出PPT 在免費的情況下完全不花錢你
就可以直接生成一份PPT的格式
非常非常的輕松簡便
下一招
這章沒有demo 這個我們之前在玩那個office 365 Copoilot的的時候
那這個部分現在蠻少人有用的
那如果你的Copoilot出現在你的PPT你的里面
我現在這個賬號已經換回沒有Copoilot的賬號了
這邊出一個Copoilot的按鈕的時候 點他
他就跟你說建立從檔案內容建立簡報 那這檔案內容在哪里
你就去one drive里面你就把一分word傳到one drive
然後把那個word按右鍵取得共享連接
拿到這個共享連接之後 你就去直接用這個提示語
從一個中括號然後把那個one drive的共享連接
直接貼進去中括號包起來然後建立簡報
那這樣子微軟的Copoilot就會從你的這個賬號的one drive的這個檔案
把那個檔案拿出來
然後透過PPT的直接生成一份簡報
那我自己有用過
其實他生成的內容的結構其實跟剛剛的那個Felo有一點點像
那如果你要做進一步的調整跟修正的話
還要結合我們等一下會教到了這些技巧
不過如果你是微軟365的Copoilot的用戶的話
這個技巧你一定要學起來
如果你已經有一份簡報
那你需要把這份簡報去做一些這個簡單的美化 傳到Gamma里面去
那我就可以用這個視覺效果匯入的功能去做美編
那可是有時候
做出來的東西我不滿意或者是
我有很喜歡的簡報風格 我想要來去偷一下 slide go那我就可以去搜尋
比如說education
叫做outdoor science lesson
可是這個哦他說是要付費版的那怎麽辦
所以這時候我就可以簡單的截下來
我參考風格嘛 來去Claude
去Claude之後把剛剛那張圖片傳上來
進來之後我就可以跟他講說請扮演圖片生成的Prompt engineer
參考這張圖片的內容風格
協助我生成 1920*1080的簡報底圖 使用SVG格式輸出
中間不要放內容
保持凈空
把相關的設計元素放在圖片的四個角落
好 那我們來看看他
好 他就會去生成這個SVG的這個圖片的格式 那我給他一張參考圖片
然後他就可以幫我生成這張
類似風格的圖片 然後讓我們來看一下這次的效果如何
SVG的圖像生成是Claude做的最好 其他的Gemini Chatgpt我們有試過
通常效果都不會有Claude這麽的漂亮 不過你可以試試看
如果你有成功麻煩在影片下面留言跟我們分享
好了 所以你就獲得一份這樣的一個圖片
那你就可以把這個圖片下載SVG
那這樣子你就獲得了一份SVG的圖檔
那因為是SVG的格式
所以你在放大縮小的時候 它的解析度其實是不會有明顯的差異的
所以透過這樣的方式你就可以請AI幫你參考一些圖片
然後把這些東西 變成一份簡報然後提示語就是要求他把中間留白
因為你要拿來放內容 然後把一些設計元素把它放到邊邊去
那這樣子就可以生成一份漂亮的簡報底圖
那Claude除了
做底圖之外 我們還可以請他去做一些就是分析資訊圖表的生成
蘋果前陣子發表了新的iPad
比較好了
比如說11吋iPad Pro
11吋 M3 那我就把這個文字選起來
把它選起來然後進去 這次我們一樣是用Claude這套AI
請使用SVG語法繪制一個SWOT分析矩陣
然後分析
最新的iPad
規格參考資料如下 冒號貼過來 送出
所以透過SVG的格式除了剛剛生成簡報底圖之外
其實你也可以請Claude這個大型的AI的大腦去協助幫你去分析資料
還不錯
所以呢
他透過他的AI大腦核心去分析你給他的這些分析資料
然後就可以幫你直接做成SVG的圖表 那當然你也可以直接把他下載成SVG
或者是他這邊其實也可以給你就是真實的網頁原始碼
你可以自己改或者是要求AI來改好 所以除了史瓦特分析之外
我們這里還有做過一些像是Pestel分析框架
或者是什麽BCG矩陣
只要你想得到 這是知名的圖表叫AI去幫你做資料分析
結果要求用SVG的這個格式去做輸出 這樣子你就可以在簡報里面做出一個
非常完整且精美的
資料分析的圖表
好下一個Napkin 這個我們之前有一支影片教
如果你還沒有看 麻煩可以去看一下
Napkin前陣子又更新了一個小小的功能
但這功能超級的好用
比如說我們進去Napkin 然後做一個blacnk Napkin
Claude這個SWOT分析的結果
比如說這些 文字貼上去之後
我針對這些東西我可以直接再生成一張圖表
這個是你在Claude里面比較沒有辦法進一步的在生成圖片
它適合的內容是把很多東西變成很精簡的東西
可是Napkin它可以讓你把原本很亂的一些文字再變成一個系列的圖示
好 所以你可以使用Napkin拿去生好像這樣的一個圖表
可是像這種圖表你什麽厲害呢
沒有什麽了不起 對不對
重點是直接輸出
現在最新的輸出格式就做PPT 還記得我們這節重點是在作簡報
所以Napkin現在支援把文字轉成圖表之後
然後這些圖表它是獨立的元件
所以你就可以做簡報動畫
各位你就可以在這個簡報里面 你可以選擇比如說一開始是隱藏的
那我就可以直接秀出來好
所以這你可以在後續去做後續的這些簡報的內容動畫制作的時候
在Napkin生成圖片之後
他不是變成一張圖
他是變成很多的原件
原件變成PPT的格式輸出之後
你就可以在PPT里面針對這些原件去做各種各樣的動畫特效
那接下來最後我想要提醒各位一件事
這也是我們最近出去上課的時候最常問到的一件事
就是AI生成的這些圖片圖表
版權到底怎麽算
簡單的兩件事
第一個就是AI生成的文字類的內容
只要你有跟AI有互動 那基本上版權就是你個人的
應該沒有什麽太大問題
那圖片的部分
我會建議各位使用可以商業使用的AI工具
比如說Napkin是可以商業使用的
Recraft Canva Midjourney Adobe firefly啊那ChatGPT生成的圖片可不可以商業使用呢
Claude那當然沒有問題
因為他那個圖片就是資料分析生成SVG那個是可以商業使用沒有問題
ChatGPT的圖片是一個比較有趣的東西 ChatGPT他說
他將輸出的內容想要這一切權利 所有權 利益全部讓給你
所以你是可以合法的使用ChatGPT生成的圖片圖表來去做商業的使用
但是他說你應自行負責內容合法性
確保不違反其任何適用的法律或條款
所以簡單來說就是ChatGPT把球踢給你
就你可以用
你可以自由自在生成
但是生成的內容如果有侵權請自行負責
所以你要自己去檢查這個風格或者是這個原件
到底有沒有侵權的可能性
這個你得自己做一些判斷
所以如果你是應用在工作上的話 如果這東西真的很危險很重要的話
我會建議各位出去之前最好都還是給律師好稍微看一下
避免到時候會很麻煩
我們利用一集影片
快速的把所有跟AI做簡報有關的所有技巧一次性全部交給各位
如果這支影片對你有幫助的話
麻煩幫我按讚訂閱分享
還有我們下面有開通了粉絲熱推的功能
也麻煩你幫我們按一下粉絲熱推
然後把這支影片分享給更多還沒有學會使用AI做簡報的好朋友
今天影片就到這個地方
我們下期影片再見嘍 拜拜